The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
We were talking about the
energies of the various states
in a multi-electron atom.
And the question is,
how do we know what these
energies are,
experimentally?
And the technique that we use
to know those energies is
something called photoelectron
spectroscopy.
In principle,
it is the same kind of
spectroscopy as when we talked
about photoemission from a
solid, the photoelectron effect
explained by Einstein.
And, by the way,
I put on the website an article
that is really very clear about
what Einstein's contributions
were.
In particular,
in explaining the photoelectric
effect.
And it has some sociology in
it, too.
It is a really easy-to-read
article.
I encourage you to take a look
at it as a study break sometime.
Anyway.
The idea here is the same,
the photoelectron spectroscopy
off of atoms and molecules.
It is the same thing as the
photoelectron emission from a
solid, in that you send in a
photon and that causes an
electron to be ejected.
But, unlike the solid where we
essentially had just one state
at a particular energy,
in an atom or a molecule,
we have many different states
with many different energies.
And what we typically do,
then, is we send in a photon
that will be able to ionize all
of those electrons.
That is, it is a photon with
enough energy to rip off even
the most strongly bound
electron.
And so, that photon is
typically an X-ray photon.
For example,
we take this unsuspecting neon
atom, and we bring in an X-ray
photon and make neon plus.
And one of the electrons that
can come off is,
of course, the 2p electron,
here, so that the ion
configuration is
1s 2 2s 2 2p 5.
And then, of course,
another possible electron to be
pulled off is that 2s electron.
The electron configuration is
1s 2 2s 1 2p 6.
And then, finally,
if the photon has enough
energy, we can pull off the 1s
electron, to make the 1s 1 2s 2
configuration,
2s 2p6 configuration.
And what we then do in this
technique is we measure the
kinetic energies of all the
electrons that come off.
We measure the kinetic energies
and disperse them so that we get
a plot of the number of
electrons with a particular
kinetic energy.
The plot is what I show you
here, number of electrons versus
the kinetic energy.
And what you see is that we
have three kinetic energies that
show up.
We have electrons with three
different kinetic energies.
We have three different kinetic
energies because in neon,
we had three states with
different energies.
So, for example,
this energy,
384 eV, that corresponds to the
electrons that were pulled off,
electrons that were in that 1s
state.
That is the most strongly bound
For example,
if this is the energy of our
incident photon,
and then this is the ionization
energy, which is going to be
largest for the 1s electron
because it is most strongly
bound, well, then,
the energy difference between
the incident energy and that
ionization energy is the kinetic
energy of the electron.
That is the leftover energy
that goes into the kinetic
energy of the electron.
That is going to be smallest
because that 1s electron is most
strongly bound.
Then we have this kinetic
energy here, electrons with that
kinetic energy were electrons
sitting in the 2s state.
That has higher kinetic energy
because they are less strongly
bound.
This is the energy of the
incident photon.
This is the ionization energy
of that 2s electron.
That leftover energy,
then, is that kinetic energy.
And then, finally,
this is the feature that
represents the electrons in the
2p state.
They are least strongly bound.
If this is the incident energy,
this is that ionization energy
for the 2p state.
All of this energy is leftover
to go into kinetic energy of
that 2p electron moving away
from the atom.
And so, in general,
as the kinetic energy goes up,
the binding energy here is
getting less and less negative.
It is getting weaker and
weaker.
Or, in other words,
as the kinetic energy goes up,
the binding energy is getting
more negative in this direction.
Very quickly,
if you look at a photoelectron
spectrum and you see three lines
like this, you know you have
three states at three different
energies.
And you always know that the
highest kinetic energy means the
least strongly bound electron,
the lowest kinetic energy means
the most strongly bound
electron.
And then, we can use these
results to actually calculate
the binding energies of the
electrons by conservation of
energy.
And this you have to know for
the exam.
Incident energy is that
ionization energy or the work
function, in the case of the
solid, plus the kinetic energy.
Or, I can turn this around.
I can solve for the ionization
energy.
That will be the incident
energy, which is right here.
This is the energy of that
X-ray photon,
1,253 eV, minus the kinetic
energies that we actually
measure, which are going to give
us those ionization energies for
each one of the electrons in
their corresponding state.
And then, once we have those
ionization energies,
it is easy to turn it into a
binding energy because that
ionization energy is equal to
minus that binding energy.
For example,
since the ionization energy,
the 1s electron,
is 870 eV, the binding energy
of that 1s electron is minus 870
eV.
And I also want you to notice
just how much more strongly
bound that electron in the 1s
state is compared to the
electrons in the n equals 2
shell.
That is because that n equals 1
shell is much closer in to the
nucleus, where that attractive
interaction is much stronger.
And, therefore,
this electron is much more
strongly bound than those
electrons in the n equals 2
state.
Of course, 2s is lower in
energy than 2p,
and that is important.
This is because in the 2s
state, you have a finite
probability of being really
close to the nucleus.
That is what makes that 2s a
little bit lower in energy than
the 2p.
Now, what we are going to do is
I am going to start lecturing
about trends in the Periodic
Table, and this is where the
questions come for your section.
Oh, okay.
Do you have any extra paper?
Not much.
Well, the way you were going to
be able to answer a question for
your recitation was by making a
paper airplane and launching it
to the blackboard after I say
launch.
And the first paper airplane to
hit the blackboard,
well, you will have the
opportunity to answer the
question.
Your recitation will have that
opportunity to answer the
question.
And we will keep score.
Now, we are kind of running out
of extra paper.
You can take the one page that
asks for the seating plan that
you will not need again,
as a piece of paper to make an
airplane.
Do you have any other paper?
Here are a couple of extra
pages.
Also, if you need some,
there are some paper airplanes
up here.
You are welcome to take those.
Okay.
Some of you are more
strategically placed than
others, and so you may want to
designate someone in your
recitation section as a launcher
and send them down here so that
everybody gets an equal chance.
That is fine with me.
And, as I said,
if anybody wants a paper
airplane.
Oh, also the other thing,
write your recitation section
number on the airplane so that I
can identify which airplane and
what section it comes from.
And they have to be airplanes.
They cannot be wads.
And here are some extra
airplanes if you want.
You can take some and pass them
back if you want.
While you are doing that,
I am going to start lecturing
here about trends in the
Periodic Table.
And, of course,
it is these electron
configurations that allow us to
understand the trends in the
Periodic Table.
But you should realize that the
Periodic Table was initially put
together by Mendeleev and others
in 1850-1870.
And it was put together on the
basis of the similarity of the
chemical and physical properties
of the elements.
For example,
lithium, sodium,
potassium, they were put in the
same column because those
elements are all soft,
malleable elements that were
very reactive.
Helium, neon,
argon were put in the same
column because they are all
atoms that are very unreactive.
And, of course,
today, we understand why their
properties are what they are.
And we understand it on the
basis of the electron
configurations.
Lithium, sodium,
potassium, we have this extra
valence electron in the s state
that makes it very reactive.
Helium, neon,
argon are very unreactive
because they have this closed
shell, this inner gas
configuration.
But really, by the late 1800s
and early 1900s,
the similar chemical
properties, as you go down a
column of the Periodic Table,
was really very firmly believed
to an extreme extent.
So strongly,
that it was known that,
and, of course,
human beings ate salt and that
the body had sodium ions in it
and potassium ions in it,
if that is the case,
if you can consume sodium and
potassium, why not a little
lithium?
In 1925 or so,
there was marketed a soft
drink, and this soft drink
wanted a lemon-lime flavor to
it.
To get that lemon-lime flavor
they needed a little bit of
citric acid, but that is not
very soluble in water.
To make it soluble you make it
a salt.
And, for whatever reason,
they used lithium citrate.
Why not?
Let's use some lithium citrate.
And that soft drink was none
other than 7-Up.
Honestly.
And, in fact,
the benefits of lithium were
touted.
Lithium was claimed to give the
beverage healthful benefits,
an abundance of energy,
enthusiasm, clear complexion,
lustrous hair,
lustrous eyes,
shinning eyes,
and you have got to drink this
stuff.
It was the market for 25 years
until the early 1950s,
when the antipsychotic
properties of lithium were
beginning to be noticed,
along with the severe side
effects of lithium.
And it was then taken off the
market, or at least taken off
the market with the citrate as
the lithium salt in it.
And it was really only another
20 years, 1970,
before lithium was actually
approved as a drug for the
treatment of antipsychotic
behavior.
I don't know how many
individuals suffered the side
effects of lithium from drinking
too much 7-Up,
but there is a moral to this
story.
And the moral,
of course, is that even though
we are about to talk about the
general trends along a column of
a Periodic Table,
don't put any element in your
mouth just because it is in the
same column of the Period Table
as some element you do eat.
This is a for real story.
One of the properties we are
going to talk about is the
ionization energy.
And we have already used the
word ionization energy quite a
lot, but let me just formalize
the definitions here.
For example,
we have a boron atom being
ionized.
The energy difference between
the products and the reactions
here is that ionization energy.
But this ionization energy is
minus the binding energy of the
2p electron in boron.
That is what that ionization
energy is.
We are ripping off the least
strongly bound electron.
And when we rip off the least
strongly bound electron,
we call that the first
ionization energy.
That is the energy to remove
the electron from the highest
occupied atomic orbital.
That is the same idea,
the highest occupied atomic
orbital, that is the same idea
as the least strongly bound
electron.
However, most of the time,
when we talk about ionization
energy, we don't use the word
first.
If you see a list of ionization
energies, if you see a table of
ionization energies,
they don't say first.
That first is implied.
Now, of course,
there are other kinds of
ionization energies.
For example,
the second ionization energy.
We can keep going here.
We can take boron plus,
rip off the next least strongly
bound electron to make boron
plus 2.
That energy change is what we
define as a second ionization
energy.
That second ionization energy
is minus the binding energy of
the 2s electron in boron plus.
And we can keep going.
There is a third ionization
energy, taking another electron
from boron plus 2 to
boron plus 3.
And there is a fourth
ionization energy,
boron plus 3 to boron
plus 4.
And a fifth ionization energy,
boron plus 4,
boron plus 5,
all the way down.
And now we are the bare
nucleus.
That is our definition of
ionization energy,
second, third,
fourth, and fifth.
Now comes the first question,
and the question is going to be
on the side boards here.
We have this reaction.
This is boron plus
going to boron plus 2.
What we are doing here is
removing a 2s electron.
[LAUGHTER] Remember about the
fool aiming for their chemistry
professor?
Look at the second reaction
here, boron to boron plus.
Again, we are pulling off a 2s
electron.
And the question is,
are these two energies equal?
Now, the way we are going to
answer it is after I get out of
the way, I am going to say
launch.
You are going to launch.
And the first paper airplane to
hit the blackboard,
we are going to look at that
recitation number and you are
going to have a chance to
answer.
Are you ready?
Launch.
Recitation four.
Are these two energies equal?
That is you.
No.
Final answer?
Yes, they are right.
One point for recitation four.
These energies are not equal.
Why?
Well, because this ionization
energy is the second ionization
energy. It is
minus the binding energy of
the 2s electron in boron plus.
This energy is the ionization
energy of the 2s electron in
boron.
It is minus the binding energy
of the 2s electron in boron.
They are not equal.
Next question.
Which one of these binding
energies is greater?
Wait.
I am getting out of the way.
Are you ready?
In position.
Launch.
Recitation eight.
Where are you,
eight?
You are over here.
Eight does not want to identify
itself.
All right.
Which one is greater,
top or bottom?
Top.
Final answer?
Boy, you are right.
Top one is greater.
Recitation eight.
It is greater because the
effective charge in boron plus
is larger than it is in boron.
There are fewer electrons for
shielding.
The effective charge is larger.
That binding energy is greater.
Or, that ionization energy
here, the way I write it,
is greater.
Fantastic.
Now, we are going to look at
some trends in the ionization
energy along the Periodic Table.
The first question is,
here is the Periodic Table,
as we go across it,
what happens to that ionization
energy?
Wait.
Are we in position?
Ready?
Launch.
Recitation five.
What happens to the ionization
energy as you go across the
Periodic Table?
Is that five?
Is that your answer,
five?
What happens to the ionization
energy as you go across the
Periodic Table from here to
here?
It increases.
You are right,
recitation five.
Here is the trend.
Here is row one,
from hydrogen to helium.
Here is row two,
from lithium to neon.
It increases.
It increases because,
as you go across the Periodic
Table here, Z increases.
The nuclear charge increases.
But, of course,
there is another parameter
here, and that is r.
But, as you go across the
Periodic Table right here,
you are putting electrons into
the same shell,
essentially.
You are putting those electrons
into shells that have,
roughly speaking,
the same distance of r from the
nucleus.
And so the factor that wins out
is Z, the effective charge here.
And the ionization energy as
you go across then increases.
But you also see that there are
some glitches.
You see that boron is a little
bit lower energy than --
What did I want to say here?
I'm sorry.
I am looking at it from the
side.
Here is the electron
configuration of beryllium.
Here it is, boron,
Z equals 5.
What you see,
here, is that in boron,
you have to put that extra
electron into the 2p state,
which requires some more
energy.
The bottom line is that the
nuclear charge does not increase
fast enough to compensate
completely for the extra energy
that you need to have to get to
this 2p state.
Boron has a little bit lower
ionization energy than
beryllium.
And to see another glitch,
that other glitch is between
nitrogen and oxygen.
Again, we can understand that
glitch by the electron
configuration.
Here is nitrogen,
Z equals 7.
Here is oxygen,
Z equals 8.
And the bottom line here is
that in oxygen,
you have to put an electron in
a state in which there already
is an electron.
That is a repulsive
interaction.
Again, the increase in the
nuclear charge just is not large
enough to fully compensate for
that repulsive interaction.
We can understand those little
glitches in terms of these
electron configurations.
And, in general,
here, that ionization increases
as we go across the Periodic
Table.
Here is the third row.
You also see there are glitches
in the third row.
You see there is a glitch
between magnesium and aluminum.
They are right underneath
beryllium and boron.
A glitch between phosphorous
and sulfur.
They are right underneath
nitrogen and oxygen.
For the same reason,
there is a glitch at those
elements in the second row.
Now, the next question.
As we go down a column of the
Periodic Table,
what happens to the ionization
energy?
Wait.
Ready?
Set?
Launch.
Five.
What happens to the ionization
energy?
What?
Decreases.
You are right,
recitation five.
Why does it decrease?
It decreases because?
Well, it decreases because you
are putting electrons into
shells that are farther and
farther away from the nucleus.
Yes, as you go down the column,
Z increases.
But it does not increase fast
enough as r increases.
Remember there are the two
factors, Z and r.
Although Z increases,
you are putting the electrons
into shells that are farther
from the nucleus.
Therefore, that attractive
interaction does go down,
and the ionization energy goes
down.
Great.
Now, we are going to talk about
another property.
That other property is called
the electron affinity.
For example,
if I take chlorine and add an
electron to it to make chlorine
minus.
There is an energy change here.
That energy change,
delta E, is equal to minus 349
kilojoules per mole.
That is, the fact that this
energy change is negative,
this tells you that the
chlorine ion is more stable than
the neutral atom.
Now, in terms of an equation,
what is the definition here of
the electron affinity?
That is the next question.
Are you ready to launch?
Launch.
Recitation eight.
Where are you?
You are right here.
No, you are right there.
Recitation eight,
what is the definition of the
electron affinity?
TAs cannot help.
Energy required to add an
electron, that is --
Recitation eight,
you are right.
It is minus delta E.
Fantastic.
This is the delta E for the
reason.
The electron affinity is minus
that quantity.
The electron affinity,
then, of chlorine is 349
kilojoules per mole.
Now, unlike the ionization
energy, the electron affinity
can be positive or negative.
For example,
if you try to stick an electron
on a nitrogen atom to make N
minus,
delta E for that reaction is
positive.
It is 7 kilojoules per mole.
And so that electron is not
going to stick onto the
nitrogen.
The electron affinity in that
case is negative.
It is minus 7 kilojoules per
mole.
Again, you can understand that
in terms of the electron
configuration for the nitrogen.
Here is the electron
configuration for nitrogen.
If you go and you want to add
in another electron,
like right there,
there is a repulsive
interaction.
And Z equals 7.
In this case,
that nuclear charge is not
large enough to compensate for
this repulsive interaction,
so the electron affinity,
here, is negative.
Noble gases have negative
electron affinities.
You cannot add an electron to
that.
It is not stable.
Why?
Because you are destroying,
in effect, the electronic
configuration of the rare gas.
With that, now we want to ask
is how does the electron
affinity change as you go across
the periodic table?
That is our next question.
Wait.
Okay.
Ready?
Set?
Launch.
Six, where are you?
What happens to the electron
affinity as you go across the
Periodic Table,
from left to right?
Decreases.
Is that your final answer?
Yes?
You are wrong.
The electron affinity,
as you go across,
increases.
The halogens,
fluorine, chlorine have very
large electron affinities,
because adding an electron
gives you that noble gas
configuration.
The electron affinity increases
as you go across the Periodic
Table.
Now what happens to the
electron affinity as we go down
the Periodic Table?
You guys, do you have any paper
airplanes?
We have to give you some.
Are you okay?
That is our next question.
What happens to the electron
affinity as we go down the
Periodic Table?
Ready?
Set?
Launch.
Recitation four.
What does it do?
Does it go down?
Decreases.
It absolutely does.
The electron affinity,
as you go down,
decreases.
It decreases because the
nuclear charge,
here, is increasing,
but you are putting electrons
in shells that are farther away
from the nucleus.
The overall effect is that that
r dependence dictates,
and the electron affinity goes
down.
Let me do one more here.
Or, maybe a couple more.
Now, what I want to ask is
about the atomic radius.
And what I want to know is what
happens to r as you go across
the Periodic Table.
I am getting out of the way.
Wait.
Ready?
Set?
I haven't said launch yet.
Ready?
Set?
Go.
Recitation one.
What happens to r?
Decreases.
It decreases.
It goes down.
This is important.
It goes down,
here, because Z is increasing.
Z is increasing,
and you are putting electrons
into the same shell.
And so the same shell means the
same distance from the nucleus.
Larger Z, the radius actually
goes down, the size goes down.
And then, one more question.
What happens as you go down the
Periodic Table?
I am going to get out of the
way.
Ready?
Set?
Go.
One.
It decreases?
What did you say?
Increases.
It does increase because you
are putting electrons into
shells farther and farther away.
What is the score,
Christine?
Fantastic.